person decided to leave their home and
to Target individuals on the streets of
Southwest Philadelphia Monday night
police say a 40 year old man opened fire
hitting at least seven people when
police arrived at the scene they could
hear the gunshots ringing out
officers Tracked Down the alleged gunmen
and cornered him in an alley he was
taken into custody police say he was
wearing a bulletproof vest with multiple
rounds of ammunition in it armed with an
AR sell rifle and handgun officers
arrested another person but their
connection to the alleged shooter is
unclear as victims were being shot we
have another person that we believe
acquired a gun and returned fire in the
direction of the shooter that we have in
custody the ages of the four victims
killed range from 20 to 59. police
believe a fifth victim who was
discovered dead in his home just after
midnight is related to the shooting two
children were injured aged 2 and 13
years old they were taken to a hospital